2.6 million couples are expected to tie
the knot this year 20 more than the
pre-pandemic average
the not wedding survey found last year's
average wedding cost
34 000. and inflation is sure to push
that number even higher esther lee
deputy editor at the knot is here to
help you save money whether you're
planning a wedding this year or merely
attending one uh esther thank you for
being here 34 000 is a ton and you're
telling me it's going to go up in what
areas so what we're seeing this year is
of course it's a record year for
weddings and indeed the 34 000 was the
average in 2021. wedding industry isn't
immune to the inflation that's currently
happening but what we are seeing is that
couples are more excited than ever to
celebrate as our guests too and that's
what we're seeing from our data if you
call up a place and you're gonna rent it
and you tell them it's just a party not
a wedding just a party do you think
you'll get a better deal
that's not the case we always recommend
that couples do go in with transparency
uh because you know vendors really do
want to give you the best day and of
course weddings are exceptional so
imagine just having a party versus a
wedding
the vendors will actually make it happen
because that's what they do so you're
saying get the price for the party but
then show up with the wedding
decorations keep in mind i'm a veteran
of marriage here i've been married twice
okay okay uh and i i do get the
impression in my experience that they
upset wedding they're like oh oh you'll
really shell out so but you're saying be
transparent be transparent because the
vendors really do want to make the
perfect day happen for you and believe
me they know what's happening with cost
right now so as long as you're open
about your budget very direct they're
going to be flexible and solution
oriented too so for example roses are
currently two to three times the cost
because of what's happening in ecuador
people have to ship it in from the
netherlands and so what they're doing
right now is designers are saying listen
here are some floral alternatives
they're equally as beautiful and listen
it'll work for your budget too and so
have these conversations that's what
we're encouraging couples to do right
now what's the best way to save money uh
one of the best ways to save money
actually is back to florals again take
your decor from the ceremony and
transfer to the reception it's such a
hack that we tell couples to do
also figure out your top three
priorities so like for your budget what
is it that you want do you want this
caterer do you want carbon to cater your
food do you want this specific band and
also have these discussions and then
allocate your budget appropriately from
there we see that um guests of weddings
are
the number is going to go up from
previous years of course um so the
question is if somebody's sitting back
saying i want to go to this wedding i
also want to get a gift but i don't want
to break my bank doing so that is
selfish
you invited me it's selfish that you
invited me uh so how can somebody save
money on gift giving
so one of the main tips that we have for
all guests and again like you're super
excited to celebrate this year right is
to go to the couple's wedding registry
because they took the time to create it
whether it's the experiences like the
honeymoon fund or they actually have the
kitchenaid stand mixer that they've been
eyeing together um the guests can find
an amalgamation of all types of price
points and they can purchase from there
so get started sooner or later find the
list and then grab the cheapest thing
also i did want to say this it's also
about your relation to the couple right
oh that makes sense yeah so the closer
you are the more inclined that you
probably will be to give more to support
that couple um i'm going to a wedding in
a few weeks and i'm super i'm actually
in it as a bridesmaid also you got to
break the banks oh yeah i don't know
well the couple is a little bit excited
about you know the fact that i don't
have to do a destination wedding i'll
just be upstate in new york which is
nice is there a sort of um
special price point you know even though
you're talking about the gifts that they
may have online but is a hundred dollars
in a card fifty dollars in a card is
that does that work fifty dollars is
that too cheap and a card
and a card don't forget the card
well the card is a really nice touch we
always recommend to have the card in
there but also we are telling couples
listen and guess that you know it's
really about your relationship with the
couple or in the relationship yeah so
it's really how much are you inclined to
give and of course there's that one-year
rule that you have until after the
wedding is over to even gift that we see
the graphic here average cost attending
the wedding almost 500 oh my goodness
then almost 200 spent on
for a wedding you really have to not
just budget for the wedding but if you
are going you almost have to budget for
it as well i want to go back to the to
the people uh actually getting married
uh if one of those people is wearing a
gown oh is there a way that usually i
can break the bank yeah so how are there
ways to cut the cost on the gown front
i'm so glad that you asked this question
because one of the ways that you
actually can save is by going to a
bridal salon telling those experts on
site like what your budget is and them
suppressing in the cost of tailoring and
everything else and so we actually
encourage and we're seeing this in our
data too is that all brides are mostly
turning to bridal salons although some
are turning to other alternative options
at the end of the day it's really about
the total package of that cost right
yeah yeah but thirty four thousand
dollars man
you know what just on average that does
include the um engagement ring too that
does okay all right all right well that
makes a little more sense are knives a
good wedding gift
if you want the cutlery then by all
means do it okay yes the metaphor is a
little honestly just only use them for
the food yeah only for the food for
sharpening that later on with marriage
esther thank you very much appreciate it